Guten Morgen, Linos.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Du, mir fällt jetzt echt zum Einstieg kein Witz mehr ein.
Dann klebe ich mich jetzt hier fest, bis dir einer einfällt.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 461 vom 24. Mai 2023, genau.
Ach ja, gute Witze machen ist eine Kunst.
Ja, haben wir noch nie behauptet, dass wir Künstler wären.
Ne, das stimmt allerdings auch.
Ich hab mir überlegt, wir könnten zu Beginn der Sendung uns festlegen,
hier wegmachen wir, wenn du uns ein bisschen Öl gibst.
Wie kriegt man die eigentlich ab?
Ich glaube mit Speiseöl.
Speiseöl?
Oder mit Gewalt.
Was für einen Kleber nehmen die denn überhaupt?
Sekundenkleber.
Sekundenkleber kriegt man mit Speiseöl ab?
Also, äh, Sekunden...
Ich hab sowas auch gehört, aber ich hab dem ehrlich gesagt noch nicht so richtig nachrecherchiert.
Äh, Aceton, Nagelackentferner, aber ich glaube die machen...
Hm. Ist ja interessant.
Also Aceton und Nagelackentferner, ich glaube ich hab's mal...
Also man kennt das ja. Hat man ja auch echt schnell an den Fingern.
Jede andere Kleber nicht, aber Sekundenkleber ist so scheiße.
Dann denkst du, hab ich den jetzt hier drin? Dann drückst du die Finger aneinander
und denkst, ja scheiße, hab ich.
Willst ja nur fühlen auf der Kleber.
Ja und dann musst du ewig warten, aber wenn dann einfach Speiseöl ausreichen
würde, naja gut. Auf jeden Fall, ich bin ja mal ganz froh, dass die...
Seife und Wasser, Nagellackentferner, Fett.
Verreiben sie ein fetthaltiges Lebensmittel auf der betreffenden Stelle.
Öl, Erdnussbutter, Butter, Margarine. Lassen sie das eine Minute einziehen.
Superkleber, Peeling, Pflasterentferner.
Also ich mag mir das immer gar nicht vorstellen, das ist einfach überhaupt nichts
für meinen Vorstellungskosmos.
Kleber?
Dieses angeklebt sein und dann so dieses, wenn da, lass uns über die Themen der Sendung reden.
Wir wollen heute mal was neues einführen und einen Überblick geben über unsere Themen.
Überblick über unsere Themen. Wir reden im Feedback über, ähm,
wir reden übers Feedback.
Hey, du hast Feedback? Da machen wir es spannend. Da machen wir es spannend. Aber es gibt Feedback.
Dann, genau, Feedback gibt es zu unterschiedlichen Beleidigungen,
Airtags und digitaler Gewalt.
Dann sprechen wir über die Anklageerhebung gegen Finn Fischer.
Über Herrn Böhmermann reden wir. Zweimal reden wir über Herrn Böhmermann und
seine journalistischen Standards. Einmal im Umgang mit Julian Hessenthaler,
einmal mit Arne Schönbohm.
Und dann reden wir über die letzte Generation, bei der heute die Polizei zu
Besuch eingeritten ist.
Und dann noch zuletzt kurz über Radio Dreiecksland und Links auf Archive von Links unten.
Also rechts unten kaufen, links unten linken.
Links unten liken. Bleiben sie dran.
Das heißt hier auch der Aufmerksamkeitsökonomie, der hektischen Aufmerksamkeitsökonomie
von Youtube und so weiter und des Fernsehens nachgeht.
Mir hat ja beim Radio mal einer erzählt, wenn man nicht alle sieben Minuten
sagt welcher Sender ist, dann schalten die Leute weg.
Also bisschen unverständlich, aber so.
Weil die denken, scheiß ist nicht mehr mein Sender oder was?
Weil die immer davon ausgegangen sind, dass die Hörer doof sind.
Den Eindruck habe ich beim Radio tatsächlich, gerade bei diesen Werberadiosendern,
da wirst du ja bescheuert.
Also ich meine, das können ja auch nur Doofe hören.
Das ist ja eine selbst erfüllende Prophezeiung.
Ja, aber das war halt ein Kommentar vom Deutschlandfunk.
Deutschlandradio damals noch.
Deutschlandradio auch, die haben ja die Nachrichten im Überblick,
die Nachrichten im Überblick, also die scheinen da wirklich so ein bisschen,
die scheinen echt richtig gute psychologische Kenntnisse zu haben,
wie man Leuten etwas vermittelt.
Ja, haben wir ja jetzt auch, machen wir ja jetzt auch die Nachrichten im Überblick.
Sie hören Logbuchnetzpolitik, bleiben sie dran.
Beim nächsten Signal ist es… Ja, also wie gesagt, alle sieben Minuten müsst
ihr ja irgendwie wissen, wo ihr seid, sonst wisst ihr nicht mehr, wo ihr seid.
So einfach ist das. So einfach ist das.
Aber das Gute ist, wenn du dich festklebst, ändert sich das nicht so oft, wo du bist.
Wieso läuft dann die Zeit schneller?
Nö, aber du kommst auf jeden Fall erstmal nicht mehr weg.
Achso. Okay.
Wir reden ja gleich erst über die letzte Generation.
Dann reden wir jetzt erstmal über unser Feedback. Erste Feedback ist von Leo.
An mich. An, es ist alles an dich. Du erzählst immer Unsinn und dann kommt das
ganze Feedback so. Das ist so ein Troll-Move. Ist eigentlich ganz geil. Das erzeugt ja Klicks.
Wie kriegst du aus dem Internet eine richtige Antwort? Nicht indem du die Frage
stellst, sondern indem du eine falsche reinschreibst.
Genau, deswegen erzählen wir heute. Das ist doch nur Unsinn.
Damit die Leute alle drüber aufregen, so, oh, ey, Lean und Late Film,
man, so voll am Thema vorbei. Boah, Boomer, Boomer. Echt, ich bin kein Boomer.
Und ich bin kein Boomer und kein Gen Z.
Ich weiß auch immer nur, was ich nicht bin, aber welche Generation ich eigentlich
wirklich bin, weiß ich nicht.
Gen Z sind die die die ganze Zeit loben muss, sonst werden die pampeig oder
kriegen Burnout, hab ich heute gehört.
Du musst dich aber doch ein bisschen lachen,
sonst werden die pampeig oder kriegen Burnout, ich sag da nichts drüber,
das fand ich auf jeden Fall irgendwie lustig.
Leo schreibt, lieber Linus, es ist richtig, dass man Hurensohn nicht beleidigend
und am besten gar nicht verwenden sollte. Das gilt gleichermaßen für Unterschicht.
Der Begriff Unterschicht ist ein klassistischer Begriff, der dazu dient,
die Klasse der ärmsten Arbeiter und anderer Menschen mit schlechter sozioökonomischer
Stellung zu bezeichnen.
Es ist keinesfalls verwerflich, dieser Klasse anzugehören. Die herabsetzende
Verwendung dieses Begriffs zur Stigmatisierung einer Gruppe,
die Solidarität statt Stigmatisierung verdient.
Hat der Leo recht? Zumal wir ja in den sozialen Schichten auch hier in der Sendung
regelmäßig die mangelnde Durchlässigkeit und Aufstiegschancen bemängeln,
sodass relativ klar ist, dass Gruppe Solidarität statt Stigmatisierung verdient.
Nächster Kommentar, da haben wir gleich mehrere im Angebot, rund um unsere Diskussion zu AirTags.
Zunächst einmal Martin. Apple AirTag kennt zwei Modi. A.
AirTag hat das eigene iPhone in der Nähe, tauscht sich mit Bluetooth verschlüsselt
und für andere unsichtbar aus. B.
AirTag ist alleine und schickt komplett random aussehende Schlüssel.
Mit diesem Schlüssel wird die Position von anderen iPhones verschlüsselt und
mit dem gehashten Schlüssel an Apple geschickt.
Dort fragt sie dein iPhone über die Hashes ab. Nur dein iPhone kennt die Zuordnung.
Die Idee ist nun, dass in A auch Random-Schlüssel verschickt werden,
aber mit IsBeimNutzer-Bit.
Das ist, wie ein Kommentator oben schreibt, unkritisch, wenn das Ökosystem diese
ignoriert. Es erlaubt aber gegebenenfalls stalkende Airtags zu detektieren.
Das war, glaube ich, wir haben da in der technischen Erläuterung mehrere bessere
Darstellungen und einfachere Darstellungen bekommen.
Was davon aber unberührt ist, das ist beim Nutzerbit,
wenn ich jetzt mein eigenes AirTag baue, von dem wir auch vorher sprachen,
dann kann ich dieses Bit natürlich setzen und ich würde dann doch davon ausgehen,
dass es trotzdem noch funktioniert, ja.
Aber was aber richtig ist, ist dass wir nicht erklärt haben,
es ist bei dir, dass es direkt mit dem Telefon kombiniert oder nicht nur mit dem Telefon,
sondern bei Apple ist es halt so, dass irgendeins der Geräte,
die deiner Apple ID zugeordnet sind, das kann also auch zu Hause irgendein Apple
TV sein oder ein Mac oder so.
Und wenn ich das aber jetzt, also was ich jetzt mich frage ist,
ob das, wenn das AirTag schickt, ich bin eh beim Nutzer, dass dann die anderen
iPhones eben nicht sagen, alles klar, ich reporte das jetzt.
Und dann wiederum würde das AirTag, würde diese Funktion, ich mache das ist
beim Nutzer Bit quasi, an, würde dann dazu führen, dass das nicht...
Du hast schon mal Sachen einfacher erklärt.
Also dein iPhone hört ein AirTag, das AirTag sagt ich bin beim Nutzer,
dann sagt dein iPhone alles gut ist mir egal.
Ein AirTag sagt ich bin nicht beim Nutzer, dann sagt dein iPhone,
ah alles klar, dann sag ich mal Apple wo du bist.
Für Stalking brauchst du diesen zweiten Modus, damit du noch herausfindest,
wo dein AirTag, bei dem du ja jetzt gerade nicht mehr bist, ist.
Mhm.
Jetzt könntest du aber natürlich...
Eine Funktionalität bauen. Entscheidend ist ja immer, erkennt das Ding,
dass sich ein AirTag längere Zeit mit dir bewegt.
Das Ding, das Telefon.
Genau. So jetzt könnte ich ja quasi ein AirTag machen, das jede Stunde einmal
sagt, es wäre nicht beim Nutzer und den Rest der Zeit sagt, ich bin beim Nutzer.
Oder den Rest der Zeit überhaupt gar kein Signal sendet, dann würde dein iPhone
nicht feststellen, dass ein AirTag mit ihm.
Reist und wenn es dann einmal kurz so ein Beacon kriegt, den reporten.
Und da bin ich mir jetzt auch nicht so sicher, ob das Ding, also das ist jetzt die App,
also so eine Afterride App, und Katokke kennt ihr ja auch aus der Sendung,
das von einem Team der Technischen Universität Darmstadt gebaut wurde,
was ich nicht genau weiß ist, also ich weiß nicht genau, ob ein AirTag das nicht im Modus ist, dass es,
Wie du dem jetzt sagen kannst, es soll piepen, also ob du jedem AirTag sagen
kannst, es soll piepen, also ob ich mich zum Beispiel in eine S-Bahn setzen
kann und sage, alle AirTags stalken mich, lasst sie bitte piepen, das wäre witzig.
Aber wahrscheinlich würden die AirTags sagen, dieses Piepen kann mir nur meine
Nutzerin sagen, wenn sie in meiner Nähe ist oder alle, wenn ich ohne meine Nutzerin bin.
Mir ist ganz neu, dass überhaupt von außen dieses Klingeln angefordert werden kann.
Doch klar, so werfen die Diebe ja das AirTag aus deinem Auto.
Wenn jetzt jemand dein Auto klaut, also du hast ja ein AirTag,
um dein Auto überhaupt wiederzufinden, weil du ein alter Mann bist,
das nicht mehr weiß, wo du geparkt hast.
Wenn jetzt ich komme und dein Auto klaue, fahr weg, dann sagt mein iPhone irgendwann,
ey, ein AirTag reißt mit dir. Dann sag ich, der Tim stalkt mich.
Und dann sag mir wo das ist und dann macht der hier piep piep piep und dann
kann ich das aus dem Fenster werfen und fahr über die Grenze nach vorne.
Das war mir nicht klar, dass da noch ein User Interface hochkommt,
was einem das erlaubt, aber die piepen ja auch schon von alleine.
Die piepen in dem Moment von alleine, wenn sie bewegt werden.
Was sie halt auch damit ein bisschen zu einem schlechteren Dieberkennungssystem
macht, weil sie dann eben, also da gibt's stalking vor Klausur.
Aber dafür gibt's ja im Internet die Tricks, wo man genau reinbohren muss,
damit der Speaker kaputt ist.
Ja klar, natürlich, das kann man machen. Aber jetzt mal nur so vom unmodifizierten
Gerät ausgehend, also wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel am Fahrrad hast und jemand
schiebt dein Fahrrad weg, dann beschwert sich halt sofort das Fahrrad, wo gehst du mit mir hin?
Also ah ok, piep piep piep, das mach ich mal ab. Von daher ist es halt an der Stelle.
Ungünstig?
Naja, also das ist halt so, Apple sagt ja auch von Anfang an,
das ist kein System um das Klauen zu verhindern, sondern wir wollen,
dass du deine Sachen wieder findest, aber es ist nicht im eigentlichen Sinne
als Klauschutz konzipiert.
Dritter länglicher Kommentar von Strudelkeks bezüglich Airtex und Co.
Die Grenzkosten bei einem Missbrauch zu erhöhen ist, wie Linus es richtig beschreibt,
der wahrscheinlich sinnvollste Weg. Auch Fabians Hack ist nicht so massentauglich
und mit erheblichen Ressourcen, Zeit, Wissen verbunden und würde darunter fallen.
Aus Fachkreisen gibt es noch zwei weitere Forderungen, um die Grenzkosten zu
erhöhen, wo mich eure Meinung interessieren würde. Erstens, die Hersteller sollen
den Sicherheitsbehörden eine Möglichkeit geben, leicht, z.B.
Mit Richterbeschluss zu einem gefundenen AirTag, z.B.
Auto von Frau, den Eigentümer zu ermitteln.
Zweitens, wenn sich mehr als x AirTags, z.B. 10, einer Person dauerhaft nicht
in seiner Nähe befinden, soll
es eine Überprüfung oder Meldung an zentrale Stellen oder Behörden geben.
Erfahrung von Beratungsstellen sei, dass Täter häufig sehr viele Trecker in
verschiedenen Sachen der Betroffenen verstecken.
Insbesondere im Kontext Trennung nach Umfeld von häuslicher Gewalt.
Ähm, okay, also das erste erscheint mir… bläh, ist so ne Sache.
Also Ermittlungen des Eigentümers, zum Beispiel mit Richterbeschluss.
Also das klingt erstmal natürlich sinnvoll, aber da würde ich zum Beispiel sicherstellen
wollen, dass die Polizei auch wirklich das AirTag hat. Ja, also dass man sagen
kann, hier, das haben wir.
Dann müsste man den Zweck einschränken, weil das heißt dann im nächsten,
wenn die jetzt, keine Ahnung, Also...
Das würde ja dann beispielsweise auch heißen, dass irgendjemand, der sich,
sagen wir mal, irgendjemand setzt sich auf die Straße, wird dann von Polizisten
weggeprügelt, verliert dabei einen Schlüssel, dass die Polizei dann sagen kann,
guck mal hier ist ein AirTag dran, wir wollen jetzt wissen, wer das ist,
den wir da verkloppt haben oder so.
Also das heißt, Dinge automatisch, die dir gehören zu dir auflösen zu können,
ist ein Verfahren, was potenziell relativ weitreichende Konsequenzen hat.
Und vor allem, geht ja auch in die andere Richtung. Also wenn ich jetzt mit
jemandem zusammen lebe, ich könnte mir dann auch einfach irgendein AirTag,
von dem ich weiß, wo es untergebracht ist, nehmen und sagen,
guck mal, hier hab ich bei mir in der Tasche gefunden und so.
Du hast da allerhand Missbrauchspotenziale.
Der zweite, wenn sich mehr als 10 Airtex bei einer Person dauerhaft nicht in ihrer Nähe befinden.
Tim hat in der letzten Sendung gesagt, er hat 11 und hat die zum Beispiel im
Auto, wo hast du noch alles? Kinder, Ehefrau?
Fahrräder, Motorräder, also das ist schon eine Anwendung von mir,
dass die nicht bei mir sind.
Das heißt du wärst dann, bei Tim wäre jetzt beispielsweise jemand,
der mehrere Airtex dauerhaft nicht in seiner Nähe hat.
Ich verstehe woher er hin will damit, Leute die das nur dafür verwenden,
aber es gibt durchaus auch den Anwendungsbereich, dass man die Dinge nicht so oft in seiner Nähe hat.
Und es wär auch schon ne... also das würde mir ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen zu weit gehen, weil das...
Also ja, das scheint mir dann wirklich zu tiefer Eingriff zu sein.
Also wenn wir, nochmal, wenn wir,
auch wenn das jetzt auch schon kritisiert wurde, diese Systeme werden primär
in großer Menge legitim genutzt und es wäre schon ganz praktisch,
wenn ich meine Schlüssel, die ich damit sichere, verlieren lassen,
liegen lassen und sonst was kann, ohne, Dass ich fürchten muss,
dass ich zu viele Schlüssel habe und auf einmal irgendwie die Polizei triggert,
die dann sagen, hör mal, du hast aber ganz schön viele Airtags,
da wollen wir mal gucken.
Das ist bestimmt was gefährliches.
Also das erscheint mir ein bisschen zu übel.
Den ersten Vorschlag, da würde ich, da hätte ich auch Bauchschmerzen,
was die Missbrauchspotenziale angeht. Und die Missbrauchspotentiale dürfen wir
nicht vergessen, die werden ja dann auch wieder ausgenutzt.
Insbesondere was Tim gerade sagt, jemand mit dem AirTag zocken und dann wissen können, wer das ist.
Ist auch, also gerade im Bereich Stalking sicherlich ein gefährliches Potential.
So, nächstes Feedback zum Thema digitale Gewalt. Anne Roth.
Ja Anne Roth, wir haben Anne Roth ja auch spezifisch zitiert,
weil sie den Vortrag über digitale Gewalt beim Kongress gehalten hatte vor vielen Jahren.
Und sie sagte dann zu unserer Besprechung auf Mastodon, gestern Logbuch Netzpolitik
zum digitale Gewaltgesetz des BMJ gehört.
Schau auf, seh ich richtig, dass das Logbuch weder bei Twitter noch Mastodon ist?
Nee, bei Twitter sind wir.
Bei Twitter, me, et me, unterstrich Netzpolitik, für die letzten Ratten auf
dem sinkenden Schiff. Mastodon, es gibt ja diesen Postodon.
Haben wir noch nicht.
Okay, müssen wir mal machen. Voilà.
Das Hauptproblem hätte ich anders beschrieben.
Erstens, Accountsperren wären ganz ohne Identifizierung möglich. Das ist ja der Clou.
Und ja, also richtig, wir erinnern uns, es geht um die Möglichkeit der Anordnung
von Accountsperren und die Idee der Accountsperre ist ja,
dass man genau nicht einen Auskunftsanspruch für Betroffene und so weiter herleiten
und durchsetzen muss, sondern dass man einfach sagt, alles klar,
der Account, böse, zack, bumm, zu, ja.
Also richtig erkannt und danke für den Hinweis. Zweitens, da glaube ich,
das haben wir aber auch versucht so zu sagen, finde ich es aber noch wichtiger,
dass Andreas nochmal betont. Das Konzept des BMJ ignoriert weite Teile digitaler Gewalt.
Nämlich alles, was nicht durch Unbekannte stattfindet und nicht auf Plattformen.
Stalkerware, Spycams etc.
Pp. Und das waren natürlich auch die Kernthemen, über die Anne da gesprochen hat.
Also auch hier hat sie nochmal sehr viel klarer und besser dargestellt,
was wir versucht haben zu sagen. Wundert mich auch nicht, ist eben ihr Fachgebiet.
Und auch da glaube ich, da würde sie unserer Einschätzung zustimmen,
dieses digitale Gewaltgesetz setzt sie halt nicht mit digitaler Gewalt auseinander.
Und macht einen Definitionsrahmen für angebliche digitale Gewalt auf,
der nur im periferen Bereich überhaupt digitale Gewalt in dieser Definition
ist und macht sehr eindeutige Bereiche der digitalen Gewalt nicht zu seinem Gegenstand.
Bei der Gelegenheit, es gibt noch eine Stellungnahme des ECO dazu,
Verband der Internetwirtschaft.
Nur um die auch mal gerade anzumerken, das ist also jetzt die wirtschaftliche,
oder ja, die internetwirtschaftliche Perspektive, aber eben auch von einem Verband,
der den Nutzerinnenrechten und dem freien Netz immer sehr zugewandt ist.
Sagen, hier das ist ein viel zu breiter Anwendungsbereich, für diese Rechtssicherheit
und für die Verhältnismäßigkeit sollten hier klare Delikte benannt werden und
Tatbestände digitaler Gewalt eingeschränkt werden.
Ja, das war ja, also auch das hatten wir letzte Woche gesagt.
Auskunft sollte es immer nur mit Richterinnenvorbehalt geben.
Die Einführung eines zivilrechtlichen Auskunftsanspruchs ohne den prozeduralen
Schutz eines entsprechenden Richterinnenvorbehaltes würde zu einer untragbaren
Rechtsunsicherheit bei den zur Auskunftserteilung in Anspruch genommenen Diensteanbietern
und Netzbetreibern führen.
Auch das, denke ich, haben wir in der letzten Sendung gesagt.
Wir reden hier immer noch von zivilrechtlichen Auskunftsanspruch.
Das ist echt ein richtig übles Ding.
Sie müssen natürlich wirtschaftlich argumentieren und sagen, wer soll das bezahlen?
Wäre schon ganz gut, wenn wir hier eine Kostenerstattung kriegen,
weil wir müssen ja hier Dinge aufbauen. Dann sagen sie...
Bei dem Anspruch auf eine richterlich angeordnete Account-Sperre,
ich zitiere, die aktuellen Regelungspläne sehen vor, dass der Account-Inhaber
nicht durch das Gericht, sondern durch den Dienstanbieter auf das anhängige
Sperrersuchen hingewiesen wird und hierbei Gelegenheit zur Stellungnahme erhält.
Aus Sicht des ECO ist auch beim Anspruch auf richterlich angeordnete Account-Sperren
sicherzustellen, dass staatliche Aufgaben, wie zum Beispiel das Gewähren von
rechtlichem Gehör, nicht ausgelagert werden.
Es muss in erster Linie Aufgabe des Gerichts bleiben, den Account-Inhaber anzuhören.
Die können nicht sagen, wir ordnen jetzt mal eine Sperrung an und Twitter muss
den jetzt anhören. Für uns.
Dafür, das geht natürlich nicht.
Sofern für eine Kontaktaufnahme zum Account-Inhaber die Mithilfe des Dienstanbieters
notwendig ist, muss sich diese Mithilfe auf das Notwendigste beschränken.
Zum Beispiel Übermittlung eines Schreibens. Ansonsten pauschale Entschädigungszahlungen.
Aber klar, kostet alles Geld.
Außerdem bemängeln sie noch, dass die Funktion des Zustellungsbevollmächtigten
ausgeweitet wird auf die Entgegennahme außergerichtlicher Schreiben.
Also, das geht glaube ich in einem Bereich, mit dem wir uns relativ selten auseinandersetzen.
Sie sagen, mit der geplanten Neuregelung sollen künftig auch außergerichtliche
Schreiben einschließlich Aufforderungen zur Löschung rechtswidriger Inhalte
an den inländischen Zustellungsbevollmächtigten übermittelt werden.
Ziel sei es, das Vorgehen gegen Rechtsverletzungen zu erleichtern.
Wir geben zu bedenken, dass die Dienstanbieter regelmäßig spezielle Meldewege
etabliert haben, über welche die Anbieter zu rechtswidrigen Inhalten in Kenntnis gesetzt werden können.
Diese Meldewege gewährleisten in der Regel eine schnelle Bearbeitung und folglich
auch eine schnelle Löschung.
Das jetzt auf den Zustellungsbevollmächtigten auszuweiten, finde der Eko auch unsinnig. So.
So viel also die wirtschaftliche Perspektive auf das Thema. Aber ich denke die
entscheidenden Punkte sind die von Anne.
Diese ganze Identifiziererei ist nicht notwendig, insbesondere nicht beim Thema der Accountsperren.
Und diese Auskunftsrechte für zivilrechtliche Ansprüche massenhaft bereitzustellen,
das wird wirklich unangenehm im Internet. Das wird wirklich, wirklich unangenehm.
Ja und vor allem, wenn das dann auch der Aufgabe der Unternehmen ist,
dann wird das ein totales Chaos.
Das ist wirklich keine gute Idee.
So, nächstes Thema. Finn Fischer, deine Freunde.
Ja, wir erinnern uns. Also das ist ja ein Thema, was uns jetzt sehr lange schon beschäftigt.
Ich muss gerade nochmal gucken, in welchem Jahr das überhaupt war.
Finn Fischer auf jeden Fall Hersteller von Spy Software und jahrelang an Pranger
gestellt worden, vieles nicht passiert aber irgendwann.
Ja, wir haben also jahrelang kritisiert, ja,
im Prinzip die, sagen wir mal,
deutsche NSO Group, wahrscheinlich nicht ganz auf dem Niveau der Bösartigkeit
und der technischen Qualität unterwegs,
aber eigentlich schon seitdem, seit kurz nachdem O zapft ist, Hektis CCC berüchtigt.
Und die kamen dann in den Verdacht, ich glaube, 2017.
Ihre Spähsoftware in die Türkei exportiert zu haben, wo sie dann gegen die politische
Opposition eingesetzt wurde.
Und dass das passiert ist, blieb nicht unentdeckt und das Sample,
was dabei eingesammelt wurde,
was also in so einem Wateringhole-Angriff gegen die Oppositionsbewegung in Umlauf gebracht wurde,
Das haben wir, Thorsten und ich,
neben vielen anderen Organisationen auch, analysiert und Beweise herangeführt,
dass es sich dabei um FinSpy, das Produkt für Android, handelt.
Ich würde sagen, unsere Analyse war da die letzte,
dafür aber auch die umfassendste, weil wir haben uns sehr sehr viele Finspice
Samples angeschaut und Detail, also Teile der Codebasis verglichen und gezeigt,
wie die sich über die Zeit entwickeln.
Sodass dieses Sample, was in der Türkei eingesetzt wurde, sich quasi in eine
Entwicklungshistorie einfügt von FinSpy.
Andere hatten vorher halt Nähen zu einzelnen Samples, bei uns war dann irgendwie
eine mittlere zweistellige Anzahl, weil wir einfach alle analysiert haben.
So damit haben wir also eine ganze Reihe an Belegen zusammengetragen,
oder sagen wir mal Indizien zusammengetragen, dass es sich bei der Software,
die dort eingesetzt wurde, um FinSpy handelt.
Und zweitens, das war die andere Frage, dass diese Software kompiliert wurde,
nachdem Exportrestriktionen für diese Software in Kraft getreten sind.
Exportrestriktionen für diese Art Software. Da gab's dann eine Außenwirtschaftsgesetzänderung,
dass man gesagt hat, so, das dürft ihr gar nicht mehr so einfach exportieren.
Und wir konnten eben, das war jetzt auch nicht so schwer, Libraries finden,
also Software-Bibliotheken, die in diesem Sample verwendet wurden,
die quasi später erst überhaupt entwickelt wurden, ja?
Eine LibSQLite Version von eben 2019, was eben nach dem Inkrafttreten dieses
Gesetzes war, mit anderen Worten muss auch der Export nach Inkrafttreten dieses
Gesetzes passiert sein.
Dann hatte eine Koalition aus NGOs eine Strafanzeige.
Erstattet und unsere Analyse war eine, ein Teil der dazu dann auch nachgereicht wurde,
Thorsten hat dann auch mal mit ein paar interessierten Strafverfolgern nochmal
über den Bericht gesprochen, hat denen so gezeigt, wenn ihr jetzt etwas findet,
was muss man sich dann angucken.
Und wir hatten Analyse-Tools zur Untersuchung weiterer Versionen bereitgestellt
und dann ein bisschen so gezeigt wie man damit arbeiten kann.
Ich glaub das hatten wir so Ende 2019 veröffentlicht und ich glaub Oktober 2020
gab's dann Hausdurchsuchungen bei Finn Fischer,
da hatten wir auch irgendwie drüber berichtet. Das war 15.
Oktober 2020, also jetzt auch schon wieder drei Jahre her.
Dann kam die Nachricht, die sind insolvent. Das war im 28.
März 2022 war diese Tatsache dann bekannt geworden.
So, das war die Vorgeschichte. Jetzt ist die Meldung, die Staatsanwaltschaft erhebt Anklage.
Und zwar genau wegen dem Vergehen, dass wir denen seit Jahren vorwerfen und
eben in einer breiten Koalition schon vor Jahren nachgewiesen haben.
Ich hatte da damals mal so eine Liste gemacht.
Es gibt die betroffenen Zielpersonen, es gibt Angestellte, Informantinnen und
andere Whistleblower, die vielleicht mal früher dort gearbeitet haben.
Es gibt Claudio Guarnieri, der maßgeblich immer an Analysen zu Finn Fischer beteiligt war.
Das Amnesty Security Lab. Es gibt das Citizen Lab.
André Meister hat auf Netzpolitik glaube ich die meisten Artikel zu dem Thema geschrieben.
Dann gab es natürlich sehr wichtige Quelle auch der Gamma-Fin-Fischer-Hack von Phineas Fischer.
Citizen Lab habe ich schon erzählt. Dann gibt es noch ISED, Microsoft und so weiter.
Die Anzeige, Strafanzeige von Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte,
Reporter ohne Grenzen, European Center for Constitutional and Human Rights und Netzpolitik.org,
also jahrelange Arbeit von all diesen Leuten, ja, mündet eben dann 2023,
vier Jahre später und ich kann glaube ich so viel verraten, die diese ganze
Strafanzeige hatte, auch eine lange Vorbereitung.
Also kann man sagen, wahrscheinlich fünf Jahre später wird dann jetzt endlich
Anklage erhoben und das ist natürlich ein riesiger Erfolg,
zu dem sich alle gratulieren können, gleichzeitig natürlich auch sehr traurig,
wie lange das gedauert hat.
Aber es ist eine Anklagerhebung wegen gewerbsmäßigen Verstoßes gegen das Außenwirtschaftsgesetz
durch den nicht genehmigten Verkauf von Überwachungssoftware an Nicht-EU-Länder.
Und das ist so eine Strafanzeige, die ist richtig übel, eine Anklage.
Und die Strafanzeige ist lange her,
fast von 2019,
da wurde lange recherchiert, die haben an 15 Orten Hausdurchsuchungen gehabt
und ich würde schätzen, wenn du jetzt nach so vielen Jahren diese Anklage erhebst,
würde ich da auch auf eine ganz gute Aussicht hoffen.
Ja das machen die nicht einfach mal so zum Spaß. Januar 2013 in unserer 50.
Sendung hatten wir Fynn Fischer das erste mal als Thema.
Ein paar Monate später im Mai, also jetzt genau vor 10 Jahren,
hatten wir hier die Meldung Fynn Fischer, BKA kauft Fynn Fischer.
Das war auch ein Leak von André, der wollte ja die Verträge haben.
Ja man kann es mal sehen, von irgendwie das BKA denkt sich, oh geil,
das nehmen wir doch mal bis, sorry wir müssen euch jetzt hier alle in den Knast
schmeißen mit dem was ihr macht.
Das ist schon ein direkter Weg. Naja, können wir mal beim BKA fragen,
ob die noch was kaufen würden.
Die Staatsanwaltschaft geht in ihrer Anklage von folgendem vor Gericht noch
zu beweisenden Sachverhalt aus der Hauptgeschäftszweck der Finnfischer Gruppe
bestand in der Entwicklung und dem weltweiten Vertrieb von Software zum Einsatz
durch Strafverfolgungsbehörden und Nachrichtendienste.
In diesem Bereich zählte die Gruppe weltweit zu einem der führenden Unternehmen.
Hauptprodukt war die als Finnzwei bezeichnete kommerzielle Späßsoftware und so weiter.
Dann kam 2015 die Verordnung für Dual-Use-Gürtel, gesetzliche Beschränkungen
in Kraft treten und so weiter.
Um dennoch weiterhin Verträge mit sogenannten Nicht-EU-001-Ländern abwickeln
zu können, beschlossen die Angeschuldigten die Ausfuhr der Überwachungssoftware
auf dem Papier fortan ohne Genehmigung
über eine in Bulgarien sitzende Gesellschaft R-Punkt abzuwickeln.
Nach außen, das heißt durch Schaffen einer entsprechenden Papierlage,
sollte der Eindruck entstehen, dass Verträge mit Kunden aus dem Länderkreis
Nicht-EU-001 mit Änderungen der Rechtslage nicht mehr über die in München sitzenden
Gesellschaften bedient wurden.
Die Entwicklung der Überwachungssoftware fand tatsächlich aber weiterhin durch
das Entwicklungsteam der Finn Fischer Labs GmbH 4, der führend in Person des
Angeschuldigten H in München unterstützt durch die in Rumänien tätigen Entwickler statt.
Exportrestriktionen umgehen, brauchst du halt gute Briefkassenfirmen.
Kommen wir zum Fernsehen. Zu Herrn Böhmermann, der eine steile Karriere hingelegt
hat so in den letzten Jahren.
Ein Household Name, wie man das nennt.
Ja, und zu großen Teilen auch verdientermaßen.
Ich habe ja in letzter Zeit ab und zu mal die Sendung geschaut,
muss sagen, dass die meiner Wahrnehmung dennoch regelmäßig starken Qualitätsschwankungen
unterliegt, also das ist einfach so.
So wie unsere.
Was soll das denn jetzt?
Naja, also alles unterliegt starken Qualitätsschwankungen. Wer kann da schon
von sich behaupten, dass er irgendwie so ein...
Ja aber bei uns geht das ja, die sind starke Schwankungen im grünen und hellgrünen Bereich. Klar.
So wollte ich das auch verstanden wissen.
Meinst du hier ging es schon mehr ins Gelb oder ins Orange?
Hier ging es in meiner Wahrnehmung in gefährliche Nähe der, wie heißt die Taste,
wo man zappt am Fernseher? Hoch. Das ist Programm plus.
Also Abschaltrisiko, das Abschaltrisiko hatte ich da in letzter Zeit manchmal. Wie dem auch sei,
Böhmermann, aus seiner ZDF-Neo-Geschichte, da jetzt irgendwie die ZDF-Magazin
Royal gemacht und ist sicherlich ein politisch einflussreicher Person in Deutschland,
die mit dieser Sendung ja vor allem einen, oder zum Erfolg dieser Sendung gehört
ja neben dem humoristischen Teil, dass sie in zunehmendem Maße investigativ
gearbeitet hat in den letzten Jahren.
Das war so ein Trend, der sich eingedistet hat.
Das ist dann auch unser nächstes Thema, kommen wir gleich zu.
Beispielsweise Recherchen veröffentlicht zu Herrn Arne Schönbrunn des WSI,
die dazu geführt haben, dass der inzwischen bei dieser komischen Bundesakademie
da irgendwie einen anderen Job hat. Genau, da kommen wir gleich zu.
So jetzt gab es ist vielen sicherlich noch bekannt die ibiza affäre,
Julian Hessenthaler, der mit anderen zusammen dieses Video angefertigt hat,
in dem Hans-Christian Strache, heißt der Hans oder Heinz,
ich komm ja immer durcheinander, der Strache halt, so, in dem der Strache,
ne, irgendwie, die einer Oligarchin nahelegen möchte, die Kronenzeitung in Österreich zu kaufen,
um für ihn Wahlkampfstimmung zu machen, damit er ihr dann irgendwie große wichtige
Aufträge zuspielen kann.
Heinz Christian Strache.
Was schon so eine Räuberpistole ist.
Wenn du dir anhörst, was Julian Hessenthaler dazu erzählt hat,
die haben die Idee ja nicht gehabt, weil sie dachten, lass mal gucken,
ob das klappt, sondern die wussten, das klappt.
So, die wussten das funktioniert, die haben den ja in anderen ähnlichen Situationen
die ganze Zeit gesehen und die hätten auch eine richtige Situation gefilmt,
wenn es ihnen gelungen wäre, sicherzustellen, dass diese in einem überwachten Bereich stattfindet.
Nur, wenn du halt sagst, wir bauen einen überwachten Bereich und können dort
die Situation herbeifüllen, funktioniert das natürlich besser, ja.
Also Hessenthaler, Thomas Lohning hatte da ja auch schon von erzählt,
ist jetzt aus dem Knast raus, dem haben sie ja dann noch irgendwie versucht
mit äußerst dünner Beweislage irgendwie Drogenhandel anzuhängen,
um ihn irgendwie abzustrafen, also absoluter Skandal alles, was da passiert ist.
Zu Beginn dieser ganzen Angelegenheit sagte der Böhmermann bei irgendeiner Fernsehpreisverleihung,
machte so Witze, er säß gerade mit einer russischen Oligarchin zugekokst auf
Ibiza und würde versuchen die Kronzeitung irgendwie zu verschärbeln.
Das hatte damals zur Folge, dass Julian Hessenthaler ...
Unter Zugzwang war, dieses Material zu veröffentlichen, was er bis dahin noch
nicht konkret geplant hatte.
Warum war das, also inwiefern hat das diesen Zugzwang ausgelöst?
Also Hessenthaler ist monatelang mit diesem Material im Prinzip durch die internationale
Pressewelt gegangen und hat es, ja sagen wir mal, angeboten.
Und dann passieren natürlich so Dinge, dass, wenn du jetzt sowas der Süddeutschen
Zeitung oder sowas gibst,
das ist ja nicht die Bild, die machen dann Prüfungen, die prüfen das Material,
die holen dann sich Experten dazu, die gucken, ob das echt ist und so weiter
und so fort. Das heißt, das ist ein längerer Prozess.
Und natürlich auch der Prozess einer Suche nach der richtigen Medienpartnerin.
Gleichzeitig auch eine, ja,
also genau, es ist relativ klar und ich glaube das war auch in der deutschen
Medienlandschaft bekannt, dass dieses Material gerade den geeigneten Rahmen
der Veröffentlichung sucht.
Und unter anderem waren sie offenbar bei Böhmermann damit und Böhmermann hat
aber dann unabgesprochen darüber diesen Witz gemacht,
der jetzt quasi der gesamten Vorbereitung des Releases oder auch der Entscheidung,
es vielleicht doch nicht zu tun, den Boden unter den Füßen wegzog.
Und das war, glaube ich, relativ schnell offensichtlich, dass das eine ziemlich
beschissene Nummer war.
Die von Jan Böhmermann einfach sehr,
sehr eigennützig war und die eine Quelle in große Gefahr gebracht hat und in
Zugzwang gebracht hat und das gehört sich natürlich nicht für Journalistinnen
oder auch für Investigativmagazine,
halbgare Sachen einfach mal rauszuposaunen und damit eine Quelle in Gefahr zu bringen.
Diese Kritik erhebt nun auch der Julian Hessenthaler in Interviews,
in Dokumentationen, sagt er hier, das kann ich nicht verzeihen,
das hat mich damals in Panik versetzt, das musste fluchtartig irgendwie das
Land verlassen und so weiter.
Und ich denke, da hat er eine völlig klare Kritik und da kann,
bleibt dem Jan Böhmermann eigentlich nur eine einzige Reaktion drauf und das ist zu sagen,
hast recht, scheiße, ich nutze jetzt meine öffentliche Macht,
deinem Fall mehr Aufmerksamkeit zu verleihen und dir aus der Scheiße,
in der du jetzt sitzt, der hängt da jetzt mit Schulden vorbestraft und so weiter,
in der du jetzt hängst, nicht, dass er daran schuld wäre,
Aber zu sagen hier, weil du ein mutiger Whistleblower warst,
unterstütze ich dich nun in der Wiederherstellung deines Rufes und deiner Existenz.
Jan Böhmermann sagt aber...
Wie der hat jetzt kein Video zu Julian Hesenthaler gemacht, was Lustig darauf aufmerksam macht.
Nein, ganz im Gegenteil. Er hat ein Video gemacht, in dem er sich in seiner
Sendung mehrfach darüber lustig macht,
dass an ihn ja journalistischer Anspruch erhoben würde und dass das ja völlig
daneben wäre. Es wäre ja schließlich eine Comedy-Sendung.
Und hat denjenigen, die ihm quasi diese Quellenschutzverletzungen vorwerfen,
anwaltliche Post zukommen lassen, in der er betont, er habe in den Gesprächen
mit Julian Hessenthaler zu keinem Zeitpunkt des Gesprächs Vertraulichkeit zugesagt.
So, wer kennt es nicht, jeder Journalist hat zu Hause einen dicken,
reinen, mehrere Meter Ordner, wo die ganzen Vertraulichkeitserklärungen drin
sind, wenn du mit Quellen sprichst.
Und noch dazukommt, Teile von Böhmermanns Team, die dort journalistisch arbeiten
und recherchieren, die haben diese Vertraulichkeitserklärung unterschrieben,
nur der Böhmermann selber nicht und der sagt so, ich schick dir jetzt Post vom Anwalt.
Das ist wirklich.
Das ist sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr schwierig, ja. Ich glaube,
ich meine, gewissermaßen stelle ich mir das so vor, weißt du,
das ist der größte politische Skandal in dem deutschsprachigen Europa.
Du hast den auf dem Tisch, du lehnst den irgendwie ab oder versaust dir das
Verhältnis durch irgendeinen Dödel-Scherz, der hätte sich unsterblich machen
können, wenn das Ding von ihm gekommen wäre.
Und jetzt muss er halt die Jahre auf der Seitenlinie gucken und ist einfach
nur der Doofmann in der ganzen Geschichte und dann werden ihm auch noch Vorwürfe gemacht.
Das tut ihm, glaube ich, ziemlich weh und das kriegt er gerade wohl offenbar
nicht hin, sich das einzugestehen.
Also er ruiniert seinen eigenen guten Ruf nachhaltig, er ruiniert auch den Ruf
seines Teams, das ihm zuarbeitet.
Weil wer wird jetzt noch mit dem Böhmermann-Team sprechen, wenn die eine Vertraulichkeitserklärung,
die du denen vorlegst, was sowieso
unüblich ist, Aber wenn die die unterschreiben und dann sagt der Chef,
es sind nur meine Mitarbeiter, das weiß ich denn,
was die machen immer, so und er könnte Julian Hessenthaler unabhängig davon
auf viele Weisen unterstützen und Julian Hessenthaler hat das auf jeden Fall verdient,
unabhängig jetzt von persönlichem Beef oder nicht.
Und ja, dass er da jetzt in dieser Rolle dieses Clown sitzt und dann irgendwie
diesen komischen, wie heißt dieser Anwalt, der berüchtigte...
Scherz glaube ich, das ist auch der Anwalt, der hat irgendwie so,
nein das ist so ein Medienrechtsanwalt, den man irgendwie, irgend so einer,
den du schickst, wenn du jemandem anderen den Mund verbieten willst oder wenn
dir jemand den Mund verbieten will, es ist halt irgendwie so,
wer als erstes Scherz zieht, hat dann halt irgendwie den, so ne.
Und jetzt geht der, jetzt kommt noch der Knüller, gegen wen geht Böhmermann
jetzt vor? Gegen Korrektiv.
Gegen Korrektiv.
Und natürlich sitzt Korrektiv da als relativ kleine Organisation,
die immer und immer wieder irgendwelche Investigativ-Recherchen macht,
die immer und immer wieder bei Böhmermann auf die eine oder andere Weise dann verwendet werden.
Und können sich jetzt von dem da auch noch öffentlich angreifen lassen.
Und auf einem Niveau, wo ich auch denke so, also das finde ich ein bisschen tragisch.
Und ich finde, das ist auch kein Fall, der juristisch bewertet werden muss,
sondern das ist ein Fall, der moralisch bewertet werden muss.
So, Journalismus, Quellenschutz, kann ich zu einem der reichweitenstärksten
Krimi-Preis ausgezeichneten Medienformaten des öffentlich-rechtlichen gehen und darauf vertrauen,
dass ich mich mit denen ernsthaft als Quelle unterhalten kann?
Oder muss ich denken, dass der beim nächsten Fernsehpreis irgendwelche Dödelwitze macht.
Dödelwitze, die dann dazu führen, dass ich das Land verlassen muss.
Das macht mir echt Sorgen, weil du mir natürlich auch überlegst,
wenn die jetzt in das Team schauen, dass gerade niemand es schafft zu dem durchzudringen
und zu sagen, Junge, lass mal gucken, dass wir hier unseren Ruf retten.
Das macht mir ehrlich gesagt Sorgen. Ciao.
Also Leute, wer schafft es zuerst in diese Sendung überzulassen?
Wir können ja mal Julian Hessenthaler fragen.
Damit kommen wir auch auf die alte Geschichte mit Arne Schönbohm,
den hat er ja nun auch sozusagen entlassen lassen.
Richtig und das war ja auch eines der Themen in der Sendung eingeleitet.
Es gibt offenbar ein bislang unbekanntes riesengroßes blubberndes Leck in der
deutschen Kompetenz-Pipeline in Sachen IT.
Und sagte dann hier, deckte dann auf Schönboms Beziehung zu diesem Cybersicherheitsrat e.V..
Dieser Luftnummer, die ganz klar eine absolute Lachnummer war und ihn für das
Amt disqualifiziert hat, ganz klar.
Aber die letztendlich eher das Vehikel war, wie er in das Amt gekommen ist,
was wir auch als Fehler bezeichnet haben.
Und dann haben sie gezeigt, dass in diesem Networking-Verein eben auch ein russisches
Unternehmen war und haben daraus irgendwie einen Strick für Schönbohm gedreht,
der dort längst nicht mehr war.
Wir haben damals hier in der Sendung, das hat sicherlich auch einige überrascht,
relativ schnell gesagt, da scheint er sich verritten zu haben,
der liebe Böhmermann und es ging ja dann auch einige Zeit hin und her,
bis dann Nancy Faeser den auch wirklich rausgeworfen hat.
Beziehungsweise sie konnte ihn nicht rauswerfen, sie musste eine ähnlich besoldete
Stelle in irgendeiner Behörde schaffen,
die keine Sau kennt und die überhaupt keine Relevanz hat und wo jetzt im Prinzip
so ungefähr sein Jahresgehalt ist jetzt der größte Budgetposten so ungefähr
und musste ihn da hin abschieben.
Und jetzt stellt sich raus, dass da eigentlich gar nichts dran war, ja.
Falk Steiner schreibt auf Heise
dazu, korrekt, Cyber-Sicherheitsrat stand schon vorher in der Kritik.
Und das Schönbum am 9. September, das war ja das, was man ihm dann zulast gelegt hat, am 9.
September 2022 hat er zum 10-jährigen Bestehen eine Rede gehalten.
Das war das, was ihm dann auch Böhmermann unter die Nase rieb.
Das ist korrekt, aber er hatte eine Genehmigung vom Staatssekretär dafür bekommen.
Also das heißt, das war das BMI selber, ja, das hatten wir ihm längst,
also das hatten wir auch damals schon gesagt, ja.
Der Andreas Köhnen, auch jemand, den wir hier schon öfter mal erwähnt haben,
das war der für Cybersicherheit zuständige Abteilungsleiter im BMI.
Der hatte selbst 2019 an einer Veranstaltung mit Hans Wilhelm Dünn teilgenommen. Also...
Das geht noch viel höher, da hätte der Böhmermann noch viel,
viel tiefer graben können.
Ähm, Falk Steiner schreibt dazu, das Verhältnis zwischen Köden und Schönbumm
galt über Jahre als gestört.
Köden, einst selbst BSI-Vize und davor beim Bundesnachrichtendienst,
ist in der Bundesordnung als höhergestellter und zuständiger Beamter der de
facto Vorgesetzte des BSI.
Doch der Abteilungsleiter war für das ZDF Magazin Royale kein Thema,
obwohl er der deutlich relevantere Akteur ist.
Wir haben damals, als das passiert ist, auch ein bisschen darüber spekuliert,
ob der Andreas Köthen sich nicht gerade die Hände reibt.
Auf jeden Fall Totalausfall der Innenministerin, das kann man auch sagen,
weil sie sich hier einfach nur von so einer öffentlichen Meinung hat bewegen
lassen, ohne das ausreichend überprüft zu haben.
Beziehungsweise hat sich das vielleicht auch überprüft, aber hat sich quasi
von dieser Faktenlage mit es wurde ihm ja gestattet und überhaupt ist das ja
an sich kein Beleg für diese nahegelegte Russlandnähe,
hat sich sozusagen in der allgemeinen Panik ob des Krieges, die nachvollziehbar
ist, verleiten lassen an der Stelle einfach eine falsche Entscheidung zu treffen,
muss man einfach mal ganz klar sagen.
Und da ist sie ja in letzter Zeit mit komischen Entscheidungen ohnehin ganz
gut ausgestattet. Das kommt jetzt sozusagen noch dazu.
Ja, also alle Beteiligten wieder keine gute Figur gemacht, ich würde jetzt...
Und wir können aber, das ist das Gute, wir haben damit nix zu tun,
wir können einfach über alle meckern.
Alle doof außer uns.
Tja, aber da, weißt du, man kann sich natürlich auf diese Clowns-Rolle zurückziehen
und ich bin ja selber jemand, der versteht, dass sich Humor üblicherweise nicht entschuldigen sollte.
Aber wenn du irgendwie hier in diesem Fall einfach mal zwei Menschen das Leben
ruiniert hast, oder einem anderthalb.
Einem die Karriere und dem anderen das Leben.
Ja, dann kann man schon mal einen selbstkritischen Ton anbringen.
Gut, letztes Thema, letzte Generation.
Ja, Tim hast du mal Speise? Ich hab mich jetzt hier festgeklebt an meiner Tastatur. Frechheit.
Ja, die letzte Generation ist Leuten ein Dorn im Auge,
das kann man definitiv sagen so und man muss ja auch nicht unbedingt mit ihren Methoden,
um sozusagen zum eigentlichen Ziel zu kommen, übereinstimmen,
aber die Hysterie, die da in der Politik gerade herrscht, Ist auch,
hat auch kreischende Untertöne muss ich sagen.
Also man sucht händeringend nach Möglichkeiten, deren Treiben in irgendeiner
Form einzuschränken und da werden ja auch alle Register gezogen.
Ich muss sagen, wir haben ja schon so drüber gesprochen, was macht die letzte
Generation? Die blockieren Straßenverkehrsknotenpunkte.
Primär, ja, Kreuzungen, Autobahnauffahrten, Flughäfen.
Flughäfen haben sie auch gemacht, ja, sind mal auf den BER gerannt,
das war, ja, das ist,
und sie nehmen dabei auch teilweise zumindest Kollateralschäden mit in Kauf
und das ist auch so eine der Talking Points,
die glaube ich die Gesamtdiskussion stark verschärft haben.
Welche Art Kollateralschaden?
Naja, halt Sperren von Straßen. Da hast du immer wieder Diskussionen um,
kommen jetzt die Sicherheitskräfte durch, können irgendwelche Rettungsfahrzeuge
durchkommen, so neben allgemeiner Gefährdung des Verkehrs an sich.
Das ist aber, also das zum Beispiel, ja, also nur um das mal von vornherein klarzustellen.
Selbstverständlich haben die immer eine Rettungsgasse. Und diese,
ähm, Unterstellung, es wäre in Berlin ihr Protest gewesen, der einen Krankenwagen
gehindert hätte, die hat sich als falsch herausgestellt.
Das wurde dann nur in irgendwelchen Investigativseiten genauestens auseinandergenommen,
zwei Wochen später, die sich die Mühe gemacht haben, das zu recherchieren.
Dass sie da irgendwie einen Krankenwagen behindert hätten, war natürlich großes
Thema in der Bild und ist bei allen im Kopf hängen geblieben,
aber dass die dort nicht in der Lage wären,
Krankenwagen vorbeizulassen und im übrigen, dass alle die da stehen eine Rettungsgasse
bauen müssen, statt auszusteigen und denen irgendwie ins Gesicht zu treten,
darüber könnte man auch mal diskutieren.
Also ich kann das glaube ich ganz klar sagen, ich nehme an diesen Aktionen nicht teil,
ich kann mir das auch nur schwer anschauen, wie da Leute auf dem Boden sitzen
und von irgendwelchen, ist auch immer die gleiche Art Mensch,
das sind immer leicht übergewichtige, halbglatzige Scheiß-Kartoffeln.
Und die dann da angreifen, die in ihrem Unvermögen sich zu artikulieren,
dann dazu Gewalt greifen, die irgendwie treten, anschreien, beschimpfen und sonst was.
Und dann kannst du dir auf Twitter oder so anschauen, wie denen auch noch applaudiert wird.
Wenn die Gewalt gegen diese friedlichen Demonstranten anwenden.
Weißt du, wenn du doch eh so eine gebeutelte arme Sau bist, die mit dem Auto
im Straßenverkehr stehen muss, dann sei doch froh, dass du eine Ausrede hast,
jetzt mal 10 Minuten später zur Arbeit zu kommen.
Ja, ich glaub den Kurierdiensten und ganzen selbstständigen,
zeitkritischen Lieferanten stellt sich die Diskussion etwas anders dar.
Also klar, private Leute und so weiter, da ist viel Anspruchshaltung und natürlich
ist auch die Gewalt auf der Gegenseite nicht okay, aber jetzt zu behaupten,
das hätte jetzt für niemanden irgendwelche Konsequenzen, das kann man halt so auch nicht sagen.
Nein, das hat Konsequenzen, das hat Konsequenzen, korrekt. Ich will ja keine Position beziehen,
ich sag nur, daran, unter anderem daran hat sich die öffentliche Diskussion
erheblich aufgeheizt und du weißt wie das ist mit aufgeheizten öffentlichen Diskussionen,
das bringt dann auch die Politik ab einem bestimmten Punkt in Zugzwang und sie
müssen halt auch dann Position beziehen.
Weil dann auch nicht unbedingt klar ist, wessen hektischer Diskussion denn jetzt
nachgegeben wird und das dann sozusagen da,
wo die Medien dahinter stehen und dann im Teil des Fall auch die Bild-Zeitung,
dass die auf jeden Fall schon mal ganz gute Karten haben, sich bei der Politik
durchzusetzen, ist ja jetzt auch nichts Neues.
Das ist natürlich etwas, was im Gesamtkalkül der Aktion Letzte Generation vielleicht
auch nicht in dem Maße strategisch gewichtet wird.
Also man kann sich nicht, man kann sich durchaus die Frage stellen, ob, ob das, äh...
Ob das jetzt zielführend ist oder nicht. Also es gibt die Perspektive darauf
zu blicken, dass das die einflussreichste außerparlamentarische Protestbewegung
in Sachen Klimawandel ist.
Das ist die eine Perspektive. Die schaffen es immer und immer wieder dieses
Thema in den Medien zu platzieren. Das ist die eine Beurteilungsseite.
Die andere sagen, dadurch, dass sie so vielen Leuten schlechte Laune machen,
schaden sie der Sache mehr, als dass sie der Sache helfen.
Irgendwo dazwischen wird sich die Wahrheit bewegen.
Ich kann beiden Perspektiven auch so gewissermaßen was abgewinnen. Was ich,
wem ich aber wirklich nichts abgewinnen kann, sind halt diese hämischen,
gewalttätigen Reaktionen auf diese Aktionen und da kannst du dir teilweise wirklich
üble Gewalt anschauen, die wirklich die Stimmung versaut.
Und zwar nicht selten, auch ausgehend von Polizisten,
die dann da hingehen und sagen so, wenn sie jetzt nicht aufstehen,
dann werde ich ihnen fürchterliche Schmerzen zufügen und das dann auch tun,
irgendwie die Gelenke verrenken, irgendwelche Schmerzgriffe,
die dazu gedacht sind, Menschen, die schweren Widerstand leisten,
irgendwie noch unter Kontrolle zu bekommen, bevor man auf sie schießt.
Das ist das, was sie mit Leuten machen, die auf dem Boden sitzen.
Komplett disqualifizierte Menschen für diesen Job, die dann auch noch von irgendwelchen,
ich weiß nicht, wer diese Menschen sind, dafür auch noch Applaus bekommen.
Das kann nun auch wirklich nicht sein.
Nee. Aber das ist halt auch schade,
dass man dann sozusagen in dem Zuge dann einfach auch im wesentlichen darüber
nur noch diskutiert und von daher finde ich das eben mit der Zielführung,
also ich würde sagen es gibt Justierungsbedarf in der Strategie dieser Bewegung.
Aber das ist jetzt auch erstmal nur unsere private Bewertung und das mag jeder auch anders bewerten.
Tatsache ist, dass jetzt halt die Politik und damit auch die Justiz die Zügel
strenger anzieht, was die letzte Generation betrifft.
Ja, also sie haben...
Krasse Scheiße. Nehmen wir mal die Perspektive des Staates ein,
du hast da so eine Gruppierung, die macht diese Dinge und du merkst,
die Pferde werden unruhig, das Volk will das nicht.
Das Volk möchte diese Leute nicht haben, die sollen von der Straße runter auf
den Beifahrer, auf den Fahrradweg.
Oder die sollen arbeiten gehen.
Naja, aber vielleicht auch weil die, ja das ist so die eine Perspektive,
ich kenn aber auch die andere Perspektive, die einfach sagt so,
Leute ihr tut so, als ob keiner das mit der Klimakrise verstanden hat,
das uns so zu unterstellen ist auch unangemessen.
Haben wir sehr wohl, aber wir sehen einen anderen Weg oder wir sehen einen anderen
Weg als die anderen. E-Fuels. Nee, nicht sowas, aber, naja, egal.
Also man kann das halt aus den unterschiedlichsten Perspektiven sehen und es
ist natürlich eine generelle Unterstellung sozusagen im Raum,
von der ich auch nicht unbedingt denke, dass sie richtig ist. Egal.
Auf jeden Fall, jetzt wird richtig losgeschossen und das ganze Projekt behandelt
als wäre es eine terroristische Vereinigung.
Kriminelle Vereinigung.
Jetzt musst du dir überlegen, wie kriegst du, wie kannst du dem ein Ende bereiten.
Das muss man sich ja auch mal überlegen, die sind ja erstmal,
machen die diese Aktionen.
Und das, also es gibt ja die Strafverfahren oder die Ordnungswidrigkeitsverfahren,
die dann da stattfinden, das ist dann irgendwie was weiß ich,
gefährlicher Eingriff in den Straßenverkehr oder sowas.
Und dann sind das aber alles Leute, die sagen, das finden wir völlig in Ordnung.
Müssen ja quasi irgendwie einen juristischen Case gegen die,
formulieren und das ist der Verdacht der Bildung einer kriminellen Vereinigung und zwar sagen die,
naja, ihr seid eine Vereinigung,
die sammelt Geld ein zum Zwecke Straftaten zu begehen und damit ist das eine
kriminelle Vereinigung, also ihr habt euch gegründet und unterhaltet eine Vereinigung
zum Begehen von Straftaten.
So wie, und jetzt kommt die Definition, das ist die Definition,
die du natürlich irgendwie versuchst zum Beispiel bei, was weiß ich, Hells,
Angels, Kokainschmugglern, CCC, bei solchen Leuten irgendwie anzubringen, ja?
Aber nicht unbedingt bei Leuten, die einen politischen Protest.
Vortragen und die Frage, ob das jetzt eine kriminelle Vereinigung ist,
hängt, wenn ich das jetzt laienjuristisch richtig verstehe, daran,
ob ihr Zweck das Begehen von Straftaten ist.
Und die Polizei oder diese Staatsanwaltschaft unterstellt jetzt ja,
der Zweck ist das Begehen von Straftaten.
Während die sagen, nee, nee, das ist das Mittel, der Zweck ist die Rettung des Planeten.
Und da kann man natürlich auch sich sehr...
Ich würde auch bezweifeln, dass die Hells Angels Geld einnehmen zum Zweck der
Durchführung von Straftaten, sondern die Durchführung der Straftaten ist sozusagen
das Mittel, um Geld zu verdienen. Und das tun sie ja hier nicht unbedingt.
Aber genau, die Vereinigung besteht zum Zweck des Begehens von Straftaten, ja.
Und dann werden auch mal Hausdurchsuchungen durchgeführt.
Joa, also was haben sie gemacht?
Die Webseite beschlagnahmt, die Spendengelder versucht einzufrieren.
15 Hausdurchsuchungen, auf der Webseite war, jetzt ist es inzwischen nicht mehr,
so eine Meldung, da haben sie die Website beschlagnahmt.
Das machen die normalerweise bei so Silkroad oder so.
Hier, Generalstaatsanwaltschaft München, bayerische Zentralstelle zur Bekämpfung
von Extremismus und Terrorismus und das Bayerische Kriminalamt.
Die Homepage der in Anführungszeichen letzten Generation wurde im Auftrag der
Generalstaatsanwaltschaft München, bayerische Zentralstaats,
lalala, durch das Bayerische Landeskriminalamt beschlagnahmt.
Die letzte Generation stellt eine kriminelle Vereinigung gemäß § 129 StGB dar.
Ausrufezeichen. Das wusste ich nicht, dass diese Entscheidung der Staatsanwaltschaft obliegt.
Ich hatte immer gedacht, das müsste ein Richter feststellen.
Ja, hatte ich auch so eine Erinnerung.
Klammer auf, Achtung, Spenden an die letzte Generation stellen mithin ein strafbares
Unterstützen einer kriminellen Vereinigung dar. Ausrufezeichen.
Alter, sind die, Tim, sind die alle völlig durchgeknallt?
Das ist jetzt eine Fangfrage, oder? Also das ist auf jeden Fall eine gewisse
Hilflosigkeit, die sich hier auch zeigt, mit diesem Protest umzugehen.
Nur mal so, die Generalstaatsanwaltschaft München räumte auf NDR Anfrage ein,
dass diese Formulierung unzutreffend
sei und derzeit lediglich ein Anfangsverdacht dahingehend bestünde.
Zuvor hatte ein Sprecher des Bayerischen Länders Kriminalamts erklärt,
die Generalstaatsanwaltschaft München habe die entsprechende Formulierung vorgegeben.
Keiner von diesen Leuten, denen wir zutrauen, jeden Tag den Rechtsstaat zu schützen,
fällt auf, dass sie gar nicht diejenigen sind, die entscheiden,
wer die kriminelle Vereinigung ist.
Wenn wir die Webseite wegnehmen, Server beschlagnahmen.
Also die beschützen schon den Rechtsstaat, es hat ihm bloß noch keiner erklärt, was das ist.
Ja, genau. Achso, äh, oh nee.
Alter. Ja.
Fäser, die heutigen Maßnahmen zeigen, dass der Rechtsstaat sich nicht auf der
Nase herumtanzen lässt. Alter, das ist...
Wie schnell man als... Was meinst du, wenn du Innenminister wirst,
wie lange würde es dauern, bis du anfängst so einen Quatsch zu erzählen?
Na wahrscheinlich, sobald irgendwelche Nazis auf der Straße kleben und ich sag,
man muss nicht mehr anhalten.
Guck mal, ob wir für dich noch was anderes in der Karriere Optionen haben.
Also, aber dann hier Polizeigewerkschaft, das ist auch so eine Frage.
Polizeigewerkschaft begrüßt die Aktion. Ihr seid die scheiß Polizeigewerkschaft,
kümmert euch darum, dass ihr genug Urlaubstage habt und mehr Geld.
Was haben die überhaupt immer wieder zu sagen?
Was ist das?
Warte mal, welche Partei ist das? Ist das diese richtige Polizeigewerkschaft
oder ist das diese GdP mit diesem Vollidioten?
Ja, Rainer Wendt. Den hat übrigens, da kann man dem Böhmermann mal einen Punkt geben.
Das war gut.
Rainer Wendt, du bist kein echter Polizist. Das ist der Typ,
der sich über viele, viele Jahre am deutschen Rechtsstaat vergangen und bereichert hat, ja?
Aber die Gewerkschaft der Polizei ist nochmal, ist die andere Gewerkschaft.
Es gibt ja die GPolD und die GDP, also Gewerkschaft der Polizei ist GDP.
GDP ja und das ist aber DPolG, das ist der und dann gibt es noch die BDK,
das ist der Bund der Kriminalbeamten.
Also Rainer Wendt, völlig indiskutabler Charakter, der dann natürlich irgendwie,
Genau, deutsche Polizeigewerkschaft.
Das ist sozusagen die jüdische Volksfront und das andere ist die Volksfront von Judäa.
Die anderen sind die, also die Depolge sind die Römer.
Aber wie auch immer eine Gewerkschaft hat sich einfach um sowas nicht zu kümmern.
Ist einfach nur ein rechter Hetzer und zwar seit Jahren schon immer.
Der hat sich nie, der hat sich nie irgendwie mal um die Belange der Polizei gekümmert. Der wendt.
Der wendt natürlich nicht. Aber auch die Gewerkschaft der Polizei äußert sich doch jetzt auch.
Wer hat sich jetzt geäußert? DePolG? Das ist Rainer Wendt. Oder die anderen?
Deutsche Polizeigewerkschaft. Oh, haben wir einen Fehler gefunden auf Tagesschau.de?
Weiß ich nicht, oder?
DePolG, Deutsche Polizeigewerkschaft. Das ist die Truppe von Wendt, ja.
Die hat sich geäußert.
Was heißt die? Das ist doch nur der!
Ja, ja gut, aber das ist halt sozusagen immer wieder dasselbe.
Dass die Medien auch noch nicht gelernt haben, da jetzt nicht hinzuhören.
Das ist das richtige Signal eines wehrhaften Rechtsstaates, sagt Rainer Wendt.
Die Bevölkerung, die unter dem Straßenterror dieser selbsternannten Klimaretter
täglich tausendfach leidet, wird endlich als das tatsächliche Opfer dieser Kriminellen
wahrgenommen. Überleg mal!
Ey, Rainer Wendt, lösch dich, Alter, lösch dich!
Egal wie man dazu steht, selbst wenn man sagt, dass das...
Dass diese Aktionen nicht angemessen sind und so weiter. Und selbst wenn man der Ansicht ist,
dass da Menschen darunter leiden, ja, und selbst wenn man auch meint,
dass das kriminell ist, was es potenziell ist,
also kriminell im Sinne von strafbar ist es ja, ja, das kann man alles sagen,
aber man will keine Polizei haben, die von so einem Hitzkopf,
Von so einem komplett unreflektierten Hitzkopf vertreten wird.
Das macht mir wirklich Sorgen. Also diese gewalttätigen Polizisten, diese, so ein Hetzer.
Ich finde auch vor allem, also die Polizei sollte sich das einfach auch mal verbitten,
dass solche Organisationen in ihrem Namen auch nur irgendwie sich zu irgendwas
äußern, weil das ist einfach nicht angemessen für die Polizei sich zu äußern.
Die Polizei hat da einfach auch neutral zu sein und keine politische Meinung
und keine Agenda zu haben, ja also ich verstehe, dass sie sich sagen wir mal
im Rahmen einer Gewerkschaft äußern, wenn es jetzt um so Fälle geht wie die
Sicherheit von Polizisten etc.
Aber man kann ja jetzt nicht gerade behaupten, dass die auf der Straße klebenden
Aktivisten jetzt aktiv Leben und Sicherheit der Polizisten gefährden,
die gerade versuchen sie mit Speiseöl einzureiben.
Das ist doch der angenehmste Einsatz, den du haben kannst.
Bisschen Pinsel, bisschen Speiseöl, bisschen irgendwie so einen kleinen Gensiler,
mal den Arm umdrehen, also wir haben hier grad zwei Fälle, wer will jetzt wohin?
Wir haben jetzt hier den bewaffneten Raubüberfall, der gerade aktiv verfolgt
wird und dann haben wir noch so ein paar Aktivisten zu ölen.
Was wollt ihr haben?
Und genau, diese Phänomene zeigen halt auch nur diesen blanken Hass,
der halt in diesen Menschen sitzt, das ist wirklich beängstigend.
Also ich kann mir das nicht angucken, ich hab heute beim Doomscrolling,
hab ich so ein Video gesehen, da waren auch so letzte Generationen demonstrierende,
aber in England schien mir das zu sein.
Und die laufen so auf der Straße ganz langsam, hinter denen ist irgendwie so ein Transporter,
Hand auf der Hupe, blblblbl, dann steigt einer aus dem Transporter aus,
stürmt auf die los und schleudert einen einfach so weg, dass er halt über den
Bürgerstein fliegt, gegen einen Polizisten.
Und ich denk so, oh scheiße, jetzt kommt der Polizist und knüppelt als nächstes drauf.
Aber war gar nicht Deutschland. Der Polizist guckt sich um, sieht,
dass da gerade dieser Typ aus dem Transporter-Amok läuft Und die Polizisten schnappen sich den.
Verrückte Welt. Verrückte Welt. Die nehmen da so einen Gewalttäter einfach mal fest.
Erinnert mich immer wieder an dieses Luxemburger Polizeivideo,
wo die deutschen Nazis versucht haben eine Demonstration zu machen. Kennst du das?
Ich erinnere mich das.
Die haben die einfach mal so lange zusammengeknüppelt bis Ruhe war.
Das ging gut runter. Könnte man auch nochmal, aber egal.
Ja, also das Thema der letzten Generation hat seine letzte Ölung noch nicht
erfahren, glaube ich. Da werden wir noch weiter mit uns beschäftigen müssen.
Ich denke aber das ist hier relativ klar, hier wird das rechtsstaatliche Vorgehen
auf jeden Fall sehr weit gedehnt,
Server beschlagnahmen, Gelder da versuchen zu beschlagnahmen und so.
Das wird auch, wäre jetzt meine vorsichtige Prognose, ungewünschte Konsequenzen
haben. Nämlich nicht, dass die jetzt weniger machen, dass die jetzt nicht den Effekt haben.
Ich meine auf der Homepage von Letzte Generationen wird das natürlich auch hier
jetzt voll ausgeschlachtet, wir weiten daher den Protest aufs ganze Land aus
und rufen alle Menschen dazu auf sich am Mittwoch an einem Protestmarsch in
ihrer Nähe zu beteiligen.
Was ist denn jetzt hier letztegeneration.de kann man die Webseite noch?
Also org.de leitet auf org weiter.
Ja, also hat die Polizei... Webseite beschlagen hat er da. Voll.
Naja, noch eine kurze Info, auch das völlig überraschend, ne?
Wenn Radio Dreieck Land einen Link auf das Archiv von linksunten.de in die Media
setzt, dann ist das im Rahmen der journalistischen Tätigkeit völlig in Ordnung
und natürlich nicht illegal.
Und die Anklage, die die Staatsanwaltschaft Karlsruhe, die ja dann auch noch
die Redaktionsräume durchsucht hat, um herauszufinden, wo die den Link versteckt
haben auf ihrer Webseite, natürlich mit diesem Vorgehen vollständig gescheitert.
Nur um mal zu zeigen, dass dieses drakonische Vorgehen gegen die letzte Generation
sicher nicht das einzige sein wird,
wo dann eben später gezeigt wird, dass hier Kompetenzen massiv missbraucht wurden.
Ja, wir enden noch mit einem Jobgesuch bei der aufstrebenden Unternehmung Epicenter Works.
Also man wundert sich, dass es überhaupt noch Arbeitslose gibt,
wie ihr euch Epicenter sucht und einstellt.
Hier verkünden wir also, dass eine Assistenz der Geschäftsführung gesucht wird.
Genau. Finance, HR und Organisation heißt es da.
Ich finde ja HR einen komischen Begriff, aber der hat sich wohl durchgesetzt.
Weil Human Resources?
Jaja, Human Resources.
Früher hieß das mal Personalabteilung, aber jetzt heißt das halt Human Resources.
Heißt das, dann kriegen wir demnächst auch einen Ressourcenausweis der Bundesrepublik Deutschland?
Ich bin eine deutsche Ressource.
Hoffen wir mal, dass es nicht so weit kommt. Link ist in den Shownotes.
Wer also Lust hat sich bei Epicenter Works im Bereich Personalverwaltung,
Kostenabrechnung, laufende Vorbereitung, Buchhaltung, Lohnverrechnung, Reporting,
Controlling, Office Management, Event
Management, Projekteinreichung und Abwechslungsmanagement zu engagieren,
dann ist das der Job für dich, denn das sind so die Leute, weißt du,
das sind so die Leute, die so eine Organisation wirklich am Laufen halten.
Da musst du aufpassen, dass das keine kriminelle Organisation wird.
Sonst bist du richtig dran.
Dann wirst du den ganzen Tag mit Speiseöl überschüttet.
Als in Wien. Remote und Teleworking ist zeitweise möglich.
Dienstbeginn 1. September 8 Uhr morgens. Nein 8 Uhr morgens steht da nicht.
38,5 Wochenstunden und so weiter und so weiter.
Ja und nur um es in Erinnerung zu rufen, das ist die Organisation von Thomas Lohninger.
Genau.
Ja Tim, dann kriegen wir Fynn Valdonner einen Job für dich.
Für mich? Wieso? Achso nur weil da jetzt was mit Buchhaltung drin stand?
Kleiner Tipp, ich brauch gar keinen Job.
Geht auch ohne?
Geh mal arbeiten.
Quatsch.
Das ist echt die Idee.
Alright, wir haben glaube ich unseren Rant für die Woche abgeliefert.
Auf jeden Fall, das war es von uns und wir hoffen ihr habt noch eine sonnige
Woche und auch ansonsten eine Menge Spaß.
Sonnige Woche, sonniges Leben, genau. Kauft noch Klebstoff solange es geht und Speisehöhlen.
Die sind ja so doof, die verbieten dann, Klebstoff mitzufügen.
Das ist ja in Bayern nicht mehr, ne. Klebstoff erwischt, können sie nicht sofort für verhaften.
Aber ich würde ja einfach Aceton und Speiseöl verbieten.
Aber mich fragt ja keiner.
Vielleicht auch ganz gut so.
Bis dann, tschüss.